today we're talking about driving
decarbonization extending anthos next
2022 and the Google government Summit
I'm Anew and welcome to this week in
Cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news when Google set out to
achieve 24 7 carbon free energy in our
operations by 2030. we committed to
share insights and lessons that could
help others move in the same direction
this week we released a white paper that
details our experience with a new energy
transaction model that we call a
carbon-free energy manager we hope the
insights in this white paper will
support organizations move to Source
round-the-clock clean power we are
pleased to announce the general
availability of virtual machine support
in anthos VM support is available on
anthos for bare metal now known as
Google distributed Cloud virtual
customers can now run VMS alongside
containers in a single unified Google
Cloud connected platform in their data
center or at the edge registration is
now open for the Google government
Summit taking place on Tuesday November
15 2022. we're excited to welcome the
government community in person for a
full day of networking best practices
and learning from peers to help
accelerate the mission of government
register now to join us for the full day
event can't join us in person register
so you can catch the opening keynote via
live stream or on demand at a time that
works for you Google Cloud next is just
around the corner on October 11th
through the 13th join us live online
along with 1 million Builders dreamers
and leaders for Google Cloud next 2022
where we'll learn and grow together to
meet tomorrow head on register now for
online programming and the opportunity
to attend in-person events all
registration is complementary
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet at us we'll see
you in the cloud